you
hi everyone it's Jerry here's another
interesting endgame study that I'd like
to share with you I feel most
uninteresting to me at least this is one
composed by Frederic Lazar published in
1915 it's white to move as usual I
encourage you to spend some time with
these like to move try and find the best
continuation okay before I share the
solution to this one let me point out a
thought or two an idea that I had when
working this for now and that was to
take this pawn right away maybe you can
relate to this idea here where you take
the pawn and approach the black pawn in
a way where you're moving along a
diagonal towards the center B for King
d5 and b3 and at this point well we're
not going to be able to catch the pawn
if we just approach it like this maybe
we can change direction this was the
idea I had with playing King e6 and now
if black pushes King f7 black promotes
however we push with check Queen width
check and then give mate black however
does not have to push the pawn when we
decide to change directions like this as
soon as we approach the King side black
makes this one key move King g7 the G
pawns going nowhere and black will only
then push through so this idea of moving
towards the center in changing direction
is not strong enough posting the King on
d5 is not generating any serious threat
and when we do in fact make use of this
e six square black has that key move
King g7 this idea is just not strong
enough so what is the winning
continuation here well the first move is
c3 Knight d5 or d1 hunting down the pawn
king takes pawn now Knight takes c3 King
a3 exceeding the king a6 any of these
two same story just attacked upon at
this stage b4
King a five black continues to push we
continue to run after it and now the key
move in the key position you needed to
recognize for the white king from the
initial position King a3 this is setting
up stalemate tricks after black promotes
the king now has no legal moves due to
the Queen and Knights physician white
from this point would play g7 if King
takes pawn we take the Queen therefore
King takes bishop we put push King takes
Queen and this is stalemate doing
something other than taking the Queen
well light can eventually force you to
take the Queen and this will be
stalemate promoting to something other
than the Queen a rook will be similar
story we're going to do the same stuff
promoting to a bishop this is not
working either because after let's say
push it's not the only move you could
also go here right away but just to make
it really simple looking you could push
push get rid of all these pieces and
then in the end play King to b2 and you
will next win one of these two minor
pieces and the resulting position is a
draw doing something else like promoting
to a knight is not working that's a
check you could play King to c2 and in
fact just keep bouncing back and forth
here keeping pressure on both nights by
doing so if one moves you get the other
one but you could also even just get rid
of all this other material and this will
also be a draw then it's best to just
keep going back and forth and that pitch
both of the both the white pawn and
Bishop but black cannot force checkmate
in this position to Knights it's one of
the most odd things in the game but just
two nights and two kings on board you
cannot force checkmate with this
material now if you did not come
with the solution to this let me give
you a quick tip here a type of reasoning
that you could have used to help to help
yourself be a little bit more successful
with endgame studies like this it is
true that if we move our King our
opponent's next move will be to grab it
upon the knight is the Black Knight from
this position is only ever he's just one
move away from grabbing the pun if we
push the pond the night of course can
still position himself in a way where
he's just one move away from grabbing
the pawn so the timing is the same
whether we capture the pawn and allow
Knight takes pawn like this the timing
will be the same if we push the pawn in
the night place here the timing will yet
again be the same King takes pawn Knight
takes pawn the big question here is on
which square should you allow the pawn
to be captured and as we were as we are
as we saw in this composition it's
important that the night we forced the
knight to grab the pawn on the c3 square
this allows this idea where the knight
controls these two edge squares and when
there is that promotion idea
it covers these other three squares the
trick here is then to sneak the King
into this box area which does go ahead
and set up that little stalemate trick
so this is really the big idea the big
key to unlocking this one I believe and
that is to find the reason or see me try
to find the difference between these two
squares which square would you rather
have the knight capture the pawn on c2
or c3 so as usual feel free to leave any
feedback in this video in the comment
section below
did you get the solution for this one
did you try this attempt I'm moving
towards the center and then changing
directions any feedback in the comments
section below is appreciated and as
usual I hope you enjoyed it that's all
for now take
I